scientists in the second dimension have
noticed a problem when two objects
Collide energy should be conserved but
some energy appears to go missing they
know some of the energy will be
converted to the sound of the Collision
so they Place microphones to measure it
but the energy still doesn't add up it's
because they are only measuring the
sound given off in their 2D plane but
sound is not constrained to flat land
and can travel to the third dimension we
know this since we can hear the
Collision too our own science
instruments are constrained to three
dimensions but particle physicists are
keeping a close eye on any collisions
where it appears that energy might not
be conserved just in case gravitons the
particles thought to carry gravity might
be escaping into the fourth dimension
and carrying away some energy with them